i got to see your movie actually this
morning and it was fantastic
it was great and we will talk about that
but i'm curious about something
tom hanks has described you as a
director as being very
excitable that you get when you're
describing an
action scene and what you want the
actually to do you get really
wound up now do you think that's fair of
tom to say that or do you think that's a
little unfair
you know look uh he he likes to do these
bits
you know where he kind of does a version
of me like
we were he was talking about uh oh this
movie that we just finished shooting one
of the dan brown
you know robert langdon mysteries and in
it there's a drone that's trying to find
him
and of course the drone wasn't really
there because you couldn't get the
mechanics of that so
you know tom's having to do his angle
and yeah i start trying to talk him
through the action and i go you know
there's
there's a drone and it's coming but he
describes it like
okay there's a drone it's hovering
it's hovering it's gone it's back
so
in fact i don't even think that
represents me at all but then i find
myself directing him
and i start doing you know his version
of me directing him
so now it's kind of ingrained but so
anyway i was i was kind of complaining
about it on this press junket yeah we're
doing with
because chris hemsworth is a starving
heart there's a lot of great action
in this movie i was complaining about it
and he said no that's true
because you did it with me you said
there's a whale he's gonna die
he's got teeth all right so
i'm trying to help the actor taylor
right now there's a whale
[Laughter]
i get i you know i'm trying to support
the action sure yeah you're doing your
part
to create this this realism you know
what's interesting is that uh
directors on a big film like this for
example where there's so much involved
there's incredible special effects and
so many actors and so much going on
directors famously can be short-tempered
because they have a lot to worry about
you don't seem like that kind of guy you
seem like a guy who doesn't get
angry or is there anything on the set
that does get you angry i don't know i'm
not really a yeller but you know if
people aren't prepared or something you
know if they're if they're
if they're late if they disrespect the
process
and and a pattern is brewing you know i
don't i don't
you know but i don't i don't i don't
yell at him what do you what do you do
if you're not yelling how does ron
howard as a director show his
displeasure well they see
they you know they just see that i'm
upset you know they kind of they'll
they'll just you'll just see
you know a different look you know and
then they can and then that seems to be
almost enough can i see she said okay if
we see the ron howard wouldn't you like
to see what ron howard
i would this is get a nice shot of this
i just want to as i recall you made my
daughter bryce cry on on demand and now
you want me to make looks yes okay
it's true okay i'm running a circus here
i don't know there's not too much too
it's not as good as bryce is crying but
it's kind of like
you just looked tired you look tired and
like the sun's too bright
that's all that's enough people just
think get that man a sun hat that's all
they're
thinking in that moment yeah you did you
know you mentioned
your daughter was here bryce an
incredible actress and she was here and
it was
this moment that so many people have
talked to me about she said she could
cry and demand so i asked her to do it
and she did it here on the show we did
like a mini scene and it was really
incredible
and i was like i thought that's
fantastic do you know that she could do
that well
i know not to that degree but but i mean
but she's a great actress and she's very
emotional
and and she can cry i mean i talked to
her about it and she said well i knew i
could do it just had that confidence
in her broadway debut she had a
cheryl and i were there it was a big
moment in the family there she was she
had a good scene she and she had she had
to cry and our seats were close enough
that in the near the end of the first
act she's crying and i'm looking at his
real tears
here on broadway wow that's really
something i look over at cheryl and
cheryl's kind of like this
and i thought why isn't she emotionally
involved in this yeah
so at intermission i said wasn't that
amazing you didn't seem that knocked out
by that i was just blown away
and she said are you kidding me she
pulled that every day of her life when
she was 17.
[Applause]